since the very beginning of time we've
been trying to recreate what nature put
in front of our eyes
nature seems to hold some kind of secret
that makes it both beautiful and
resilient and we've been obsessed with
trying to replicate that ability after
thousands of years we've been pretty
successful in creating our own version
of the world but this is the first time
in history that we've actually had the
technology to really extract the secrets
of Nature and replicate some of its very
elegant designs I'm sure you've noticed
more and more buildings popping up that
are inspired by nature but similar to
what we're seeing with AI right now just
because we can doesn't mean we should so
copying nature is it fundamentally
flawed does nature really have the
answer to a better future does it even
make sense to scale these designs
portion of this video is sponsored by
ag1
[Music]
I'm not a religious person but I had
something very close to a spiritual
experience when I first visited sagran
Familia suddenly I was floating in this
strange Forest built out of bones or
sand crafted with such detail and a
ceiling that reminded me of the sky the
forest the sun and the universe all at
the same time
huh
Gowdy was obsessed with nature and for
him it was the ultimate source of
inspiration he would study ants tree
snakes skeletons and when he was
commissioned as big projects to garada
Familia the place of God he tried to
extract those lessons and recreate them
in his building so if you go in this
building most people will probably say
that it feels organic but there's
actually a logical reason for this
feeling he realized nature had a series
of geometric rules the hyperbolic
paraboloid the conoid a double turn
helicoidal shape creating a structure
now known as a fractal but he's probably
best known for his extensive use of
catenary arches which is formed when a
chain of uniform density is hung from
two points creating a shape that's in
complete tension when you inverse this
you get a shape that's in complete
compression you could probably call his
designs an early form of biomimicry
which is defined as the design and
production of materials structures and
systems that are modeled on biological
entities and processes but when Gowdy
started the project in 1882 they didn't
really have parametric software and in
fact they didn't even have computers
so he constructed models using way to
change then he would either place a
mirror or take photographs and flip it
upside down to understand the structure
of the building the problem is that this
project is uh never finished it's been
going on for more than a hundred years
and it's supposed to finally finish in
and I think that's the problem with
buildings inspired by Nature even though
they can be incredibly beautiful
compared to a standard boxy building
they can be extremely hard to build and
it can consume a lot of resources
alright let's look at another example
this is a Venus Flower Basket sea sponge
it looks very delicate but it's got a
very strong lattice structure that
provides stiffness while being able to
bend at the intersections meaning it can
Flex without damaging the core
Arrangement the rounded shape disperses
the forces from the strong currents and
this mesh forms a hollow basket that
allows water and nutrition to filter
through
you've probably seen this building
before it's the iconic building in the
London Skyline known as the gherkin
which is probably a more catchy name
than the Venus Flower Basket sea sponge
but this building mimics the shape and
structure of the sponge and basically
does the same thing but in air the
rounded shape allows the air to flow
smoothly around the building which
creates pressure differences that power
the natural ventilation system so it's
not only mimicking the form but it's
also mimicking the function and
performance of the organism the system
guides fresh air into atriums at every
six stories which is distributed to each
floor through its double facade this
double skin facade also provides extra
insulation in the winters and this
entire system reduces the power
consumption of the building by 50
percent or that's what it was supposed
to be
in 2005 one of the operable Windows
broke off the facade and they decided to
limit the use of this passive
ventilation system and now it just
operates on a very standard mechanical
ventilation system just like any other
building actually when we were doing
research for this video we could only
find a handful of truly successful
examples that really seem to emulate the
design and principles of nature even the
watercube building in Beijing inspired
by soap bubbles which received lead gold
has a 30 reduction in energy consumption
compared to similar buildings to build
this it used 90 kilometers of Steel it's
a hundred thousand square meters of
plastic it's not really the most
sustainable material this really makes
me wonder is it practical to scale
Nature's designs
[Music]
I've been following these guys since I
was in architecture school every year
the research group at itke built these
biomimic every year the research group
at biometric started
the research group at itke built these
biomimic biomip
foreign
[Music]
you're feeling so tired that you can't
even say basic words
ag1 is my go-to what I'm feeling a
little bit groggy a little bit tired and
it really helps me with my stress and
focus I started taking ag1 during the
pandemic basically when I realized I
needed to start taking a little bit more
accountability for my health and it was
long before I was getting paid to talk
about it it's a foundational nutritional
supplement so it also supports immune
Health gut health with 75 vitamins
minerals and Whole Food Source
ingredients I do try to eat
nutrient-dense meals but it's not always
realistic ag1 is easy to drink it tastes
good so it's really easy to incorporate
into your routine and I always take it
when I'm traveling just so that I know
I've covered all my bases when it comes
to my nutrition go to drinkaj1.com
damily to get started on your very first
order ag1 is going to give my community
a free one-year supply of AG vitamin D3
and MK2 and 5 ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase thanks aguan for
sponsoring this video
okay as I was saying the research group
at itke built these biomimetic Pavilions
every year not using standard materials
like concrete and steel but new high
performing materials this was their
first Pavilion in 2010 where they
explore the structural capacities and
the elastic bending behavior of birch
plywood strips they input the material
properties into a digital model and once
they come up with an ideal form they
used a six axis robot to manufacture the
pieces which they assembled manually on
site similarly in 2011 they used a
digital model to simulate the material
behavior and form they use a robotic arm
to manufacture the pieces which then
they manually assembled on site in 2012
see what a big leap that is from this to
this this design was based off their
analysis of a lobster's exoskeleton and
this year The Pavilion was entirely
robotically fabricated this is from the
team
so what they're trying to say is they
couldn't just replicate the structural
Arrangement at an abstract level using
any material because this type of
structure would only work with a unique
material properties of the biological
role model in this case the chicken
fibers found in the lobsters so they had
to find a material with similar
properties in this case carbon and glass
fiber Composites and because this
material had never been used this way
before they had to think of a new way of
using it bye again inputting the
material properties into a digital model
and simulating a structure that would
optimize the capabilities of this
material all of this led to a really
cool ass looking form as well as an
extremely high performing structure only
four millimeters of opposite laminate
while spanning 8 meters
[Music]
2013 was the first time they used
microcomputer tomography in their
process which gave them the ability to
analyze this time a beetle Shell at a
very intricate level from this they
discovered that the shawl is a double
layer structure connected by curve
support elements kind of like a column
the fiber layout within this column
which is called the trabecula merges the
upper and lower shawl segments based on
this they also developed a double
layered modular system again using
carbon and glass fiber Composites and
basically they weaved it together using
another new method two mirin Kuka robots
a slave robot and a master robot
foreign
so what I'm trying to show you here is
with every new technology that's
introduced into the system they're able
to more closely mimic Nature's designs
and they're able to better optimize the
characteristics of each material leading
to stronger and more resource efficient
structures that don't really look like
anything else that's been built before
just last year they introduced a new
challenge into the mix a Sustainable
Building Material flax fibers the
renewable and biodegradable and they're
comparable and their structural
properties as the glass and carbon fiber
but they have a much lower embodied
energy
[Music]
taking this idea one step further this
is a five meter tall structure by Nary
oxman Studio made entirely of cells of
living organisms AKA biopolymers it's
made of 80 water 20 trees Apple skins
and shrimp cells which are some of the
most common biopolymers on our planet
here they 3D print the material into a
layered structure that combines elements
that are like shells and also like skins
creating a kind of Bio composite the
idea is that over its lifespan the
structure reacts to the environment
changing in shape or color or rigidity
depending on the temperature or humidity
or sunlight
I don't know how we could scale the size
of a building per se but biopolymers do
have really great insulation properties
and they can regulate moisture as well
and the point here is that these
biocompositions can be specifically
combined and tuned to the kind of
behavior that you're looking for imagine
we could build buildings or Towers or
even cities as living organisms that
adapt and respond to their environment
and at the end of the building's life
cycle it just decomposes into the Earth
but what if we didn't design at all
and instead of mimicking nature we just
let nature design
in the silk Pavilion project by by Nary
oxman and our team they co-created a six
meter tall fiber structure with
silkworms they found that the silkworms
distribute themselves based on the
environmental conditions like gravity
heat and light so in order to control
the density of the silkworms in turn the
density of the fabric they've designed a
robotic Gloom which would rotate in
order to control these environmental
conditions the primary structure was a
kind of scaffolding made of soluble knit
which provided a template that the
silkworms could follow so going Beyond
just sustainability or optimizing the
material properties this new way of
co-creating with other species and
designing the process not just the final
form it gives each structure its own
kind of expression
kind of a soul
I find it kind of comforting that in
nature there's logic and reason behind
every single shape every single
curvature every single hair there's a
seamless connection between function and
form which lead to designs that make the
most optimal use of resources and that's
probably because Nature has been
developing and iterating through these
designs for like 3.8 billion years
dumping the bad ones and letting the
Smart Ones continue on the smartest part
of nature is that it's a closed-loop
system where the death of one organism
means the nutrients for another
where different species can coexist and
thrive in a symbiotic relationship
sometimes totally weird relationships
remember the Venus Flower Basket sea
sponge this creature has a very
interesting relationship with a
particular type of deep sea shrimp when
a young shrimp meets his partner they
take shelter in the sponge which
protects it from predators the skeletal
framework as we talked about before it
allows the nutrients to filter through
and this feeds the shrimp in return the
shrimp cleaned the inside of the sponge
but once this shrimp couple grows older
they become too big to fit through the
mesh and they're trapped in there until
they die their offspring however are
small enough to fit through so they can
leave to find their own partners and
also their own Flower Basket that's
nature it's a beautiful and smart system
but it's a system of give and take we've
just been taking and taking and taking
for so long using the Earth as our
playground that I think we've completely
forgotten that we're a part of this
system and one day in a not so distant
future we're also gonna have to give
back
[Music]
thanks for watching guys if you guys are
interested in all the research that
didn't make it into this video you can
find our research booklet down in the
description also I have a Discord server
and a newsletter I'll leave those in the
description as well and with that I'll
see you guys in the next video
[Music]
thank you